[Music]
to save money on energy bills simply
Place some silver foil on the back of a
radiator this will reflect the heat back
into the room rather than letting it
uselessly Escape through the walls of
your house
[Music]
thank you
as winter approaches it's a good idea to
start draw proofing around windows and
doors program your thermostat so you're
not wasting Heat at different times of
the day when it comes to cooking slow
cookers use less energy than ovens bleed
your radiators to make them run more
efficiently and whilst you're at it you
might as well turn down the radiator
valves to use less energy
[Music]
foreign foreign
foreign